[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday and it's
labor day weekend
yes we're going out tonight yeah and i
dozed off she had to go in there and go
get me well it's a good thing i came in
there to get you because i didn't know
you were sleeping
i could hear your tv blaring but i was
just kind of like i went in there i was
like is he coming or what am i like nope
nope
yeah well you know all right so uh this
is the new um sylvester stallone
made for uh
amazon
well it wasn't made for amazon no it was
actually here's the thing i kind of feel
like this movie which i wasn't really
all that aware of but this movie had
actually been
kind of rumored making the rounds it was
actually supposed to come out in the
theater
um a couple years ago like back in 2020
then it got pushed back and then it got
pushed back again and then finally like
amazon bought it and just like premiered
it on you know the streaming service
like just a week or two ago and
interestingly here's another thing that
i didn't know the idea for this has been
floating around since
2014 or before that it started out as a
spec script
and it kind of got shopped around and
they were going to make it into a movie
and then it didn't get made into a movie
right away so like the guy that wrote
the script like turned it into a graphic
novel okay so this is actually kind of
like a standalone but the graphic novel
i think came out in 2014 but this is
actually like a standalone superhero
done anything to do with marvel or dc or
anything like that it's kind of like you
know yeah
one thing about this movie is it goes to
show you that you don't need marvel or
dc you can make a superhero movie pretty
much out of anything as long as the
story is good this one's a pretty good
story i liked it
it has a twist to it danny rolling ghost
face and all the guys in the comment
section are spoiling the [ __ ] out of
that twist right now
we probably should have spoiled it
because people haven't seen it so i
don't think we'll say anything in the
audio
but um
you know some people evidently just from
the trailers or already knew you know
what the deal was with this movie but
and most reviews i saw people were like
yeah i saw that twist coming like five
minutes into the movie yeah yeah i kind
of just you saw it yeah
you know but
um it was the the writing was pretty
good it's just kind of uh
old school traditional kind of
storytellings
going along with some of the superhero
tropes um
there's uh
some kind of things that are kind of
like easter eggs
but i think they might have been easter
eggs but it's hard to tell
um but uh
sly was looking good in it he did a
pretty good job
and um
[ __ ]
ended up
[ __ ] like i said i don't i'm afraid what
you know i'm afraid of saying too much
just thank you jeffy it's good yeah it
was good it was it was worth it
worth watching even though it didn't
cost us anything
i mean the thing about it like i liked
it but i think that
um
i don't know it seemed a little
derivative i feel like because it's i
don't want to say it stole from like a
bunch of other movies but it's like a
lot of other movies and especially it's
like it's like a lot of other movies
like from i want to say like the 90s and
like the early 2000s i want to say it's
kind of like
well it's some you know you have kind of
a thing where it kind of reminded me of
the last action hero you know the arnold
schwarzenegger one with the little kid
like uh you know the whole that whole
meta thing it kind of reminded me a
little bit of that and it had some of
the stuff i don't know it's very much a
80s 90s throwback yeah type of movie
which you know i'm just assuming that's
probably what they were going for and
the effects were good
yeah and but it's a lot more kind of
like grounded yeah and because there's
not a bunch of lore behind it
um they kind of left a lot of stuff i
don't know if they're going to open this
up into like a new universe or anything
like that i don't really i yeah i don't
really know if there's enough to it but
they didn't really get too much into
like exactly what the superhero's powers
are
and all that kind of stuff
like if you haven't seen it like um you
know i'm not gonna spoil it even though
like i said pretty much every review
like they said yeah they figured out the
twist like really early on in the movie
but i'm not going to spoil it anyway but
the thing about it what you have is
there's kind of like a prologue at the
beginning which is like animated
and it's told from the point of view of
the kid who's like the main
character like his name's sam right
and he's like okay there's this
city it's kind of like gotham you know
like a crime ridden [ __ ] um and it's
but it's called granite city
i think they shot it in georgia
somewhere like atlanta or something like
that so it's supposed to look like an
old like crime ridden like beat up slum
or whatever
so uh 20 i think it was 20 years prior
to the events of the movie uh there was
this big epic battle between
samaritan who was the good guy superhero
and his brother who was the bad guy
superhero whose name is nemesis
and so there was like this big epic fat
fight
and uh they both
ended up getting killed that's how the
story goes like that they both ended up
getting over there was like a big
explosion and fire and all those other
kind of kind of just yeah gone and they
kind of like disappear
so then like 20 years later like sam is
kind of like uh samaritan is like his
hero he's always like drawing you know
pictures of him and [ __ ] like that in
his notebook and then he meets uh
sylvester stallone who lives next door
not actual sylvester stallone but like
you know the character that he plays
whose name is joe he's like a trash man
he's a garbage man
and uh he starts to become convinced
that uh joe is actually samaritan in
disguise that like he didn't
uh die and that he's just trying to like
keep on the dl
um so there's that and then you kind of
have this thing where the kid is sort of
falling into because he's poor and
everything and where he's kind of fallen
in with uh kind of like local gang
type situation with the main bad guy
whose name is cyrus who kind of looks
like kiefer sutherland if he's
cosplaying as bane yeah it's like
kind of a bane he's got the bane kind of
thing going on and uh he was good in
this though i liked him in this
but um but he seems to be having a good
time and so he's kind of like uh the
other side where he's kind of like i
don't he just runs a bunch of gangs i
don't know what their end game is or
what their angle is i guess it's just
steel and stuff it's a bane
type situation so uh so he's got like
all these lower level lackeys and he
kind of idolizes nemesis and wants to
bring that back and it's gonna be like a
big uprising or whatever he starts to
kind of impersonate nemesis
yeah like he gets his mask and he gets
his hammer like i guess he has a handle
like floor i guess like a magic hammer
so he has that and but i suppose
samaritan didn't have like a like a cool
they don't show you much weapon that's
what i mean there's not a lot of lore
one of the things i did notice about the
movie is that when they were talking
when they were doing the prologue
and they were showing the uh the
animated boss fight that happened a long
time ago i liked how that looked there
needs to be
a superhero movie that it's just that
the whole way yeah maybe they should
have done the whole movie like that yeah
you could tell it was kind of filmed and
then they illustrated over it or they
used some kind of it's probably probably
use a computer uh
uh skin now to probably do that or some
kind of app
but it looks good it just has a moving
cartoon
yeah and uh they used to call that
rotoscoping i don't know what i think
that rotoscope is partially done by hand
it was yeah this is probably
some kind of a damn digital effect
but i'd like to see a whole movie like
that i thought that was effective
because
like i said before
whenever i talk about so many superhero
movies the live action things work
sometimes but
a lot of times uh
animation it makes more sense to me like
some of the animated batman ones that i
saw i thought they were great and that
would have never worked in live action
um
like uh red sun you know the anti-super
the communist superman that wouldn't
have worked i don't think in live action
it wouldn't have been quite the same
yeah you know um well you can do a lot
more with animation and you can kind of
like get away with a lot more because
you don't have that whole suspension
belief
thing that you would have to have like
with a live action phone right like
anime
yeah an anime it can just be bizarre and
you still accept it and you'd be like
all right yeah because it's just
pictures it's just like somebody's
drawing it you know right so you're not
like hey a real person couldn't do that
some of those just some of those stories
look better animated they do yeah but uh
i'd like to see that was kind of like
about exceed like something was filmed
and then it had to make it look like 3d
animation
a good a good example would be like um
the old lord of the rings yes rotoscope
i think most of it and have live action
and animation that looked really good or
uh 300 was live action but then it
it looked like cg at the same time i
thought that looked really good yeah
they did that with beowulf too yeah yeah
bad wolf looked pretty good
was all cg yeah they made that all look
like three days yeah it was like a video
game right but uh i like i like 300 the
way they did that
um the sequel to 300 wasn't that good
but uh yeah we watched it but i barely
remember it was it was all right script
wasn't right but it didn't like stick
with me no and i and actually and until
you just mentioned it i totally forgot
that we got about that yeah
yeah but there's something about the way
that that 300 looked you could get away
with a lot because it didn't quite look
realistic yeah
um
yeah danny rowling oh i'm glad you
brought that up uh he said it seems like
a cross between shaq's steel film and
hancock yeah i've seen like a bunch of
other um a bunch of other uh reviews
compare this to hancock as well like i
said that's the thing that i think and i
did like this movie i thought it was
like you know i thought it was really
well done and sylvester stallone was
good in it like as kind of the
disgruntled like cranky old superhero
yeah it's just like a fun it's not super
deep it's not like over the top funny
it's not over i think it was pg-13 like
so they didn't so it's not real it's
kind of violent but
they pretty much like keep it down on
the like with the blood and everything
like that all you though you do get to
see like kids get their ass beat and
stuff like that which you know yeah it
was fun but not quite as fun to say
shazam
i like shazam look at her she's trying
to she's trying to knock spock
yes he does he doesn't love you yes he
does okay um but yeah it's it's just
kind of like it's just like a very
to me it just came across as like a very
surface level and they and it almost
kind of seemed like a magpie type of
movie where they're just like picking
like little pieces from all these other
movies and just like kind of putting
them all together
like so it's not super original but like
i said a lot of you know it doesn't have
to be as long as it's entertaining and
it's a fun time
um i actually did like quite like the
fight sequences in this i liked you know
the fact that it was more grounded you
didn't really have there was cgi
obviously but you didn't have a lot of
like you know big
uh kind of super dudes like throwing
each other around and flying around like
it didn't look like that like it usually
looked like real fights like i said they
didn't really say like what
really it seemed like his like samaritan
like their only superpowers were
that they were just like super strong
like they couldn't heal up and they
could heal up like yeah because he gets
hit by a car at one point and he's all
[ __ ] up which is that's probably like
my favorite scene there were some
downsides to like how he reacted to it
it was like really funny yeah he had
some weaknesses but you know it's just
they're all supposed to it's not as
grounded to see like m night shyamalan
[ __ ]
right i liked
you know
i think i have all of those except the
very last one i gotta go go through
there and see but
yeah that's the way
that for me i think you know out of all
those superhero type movies i kind of
like to have knight shambling's [ __ ]
movies yeah it's not as yeah like you
said it's not as grounded as like
unbreakable i don't know but it's like a
similar kind of vibe though because
you're you're still
um
you know it's not quite as realistic
because it still has that stylized 80s
90s
you know fake gotham city type situation
to it but it's not
way over the top like nobody can shoot
fireballs or like you know warp out in
and out of different dimensions or [ __ ]
like that it was atlanta where that was
yeah well yeah like they shoot a lot of
stuff in georgia nowadays like they shot
the walking dead there and they shut
they have like a big like tax incentive
like for all these movies to come and
shoot there atlanta is the is the uh is
the south version of new york city
atlanta my sister lives there
but uh but yeah so that's where they
shot i'm not really sure what
neighborhood or anything like that but
they made it look like absolutely the
south has atlantis atlantis rose up from
the [ __ ] south it does the city of
atlantis
that could only happen here in the south
danny rowling said yeah i just saw
unbreakable and glass after this i'm
going to watch split because of this
film yeah this this did give me it's not
exactly like unbreakable i feel like
unbreakable was more of a drama and it
was more serious whereas this was more
i'll call it an action movie even though
there's not really a lot of action until
the third act i kind of feel like the
first two-thirds of it is mostly like
the kid you know getting his ass beat by
the gang but also kind of like
befriending
joe and like figuring out what his deal
is and what happened and why he's gone
into hiding in yada yada so i kind of
feel like it's almost like
that type of thing i'm not shameless he
has four movies or was that three
superhero movies three it was a trilogy
okay i thought there were four of them
although i always thought that maybe uh
the the one about the little kid that
saw dead people is in that same universe
the sixth sense sixth sense might be in
that same universe yeah yeah maybe i
mean because that's seeing dead people
as a universe is is a superpower sure
right david june said you're welcome for
sending you some animated batman dark
knight returns yeah they're good
rob says wouldn't you think a weapon
with this magnitude of power talking
about nemesis's hammer would be secured
in a place like fort knox rather than
some police lockup
yeah they just they just broke right in
and got it they didn't they didn't
really think it was it was a big deal
they wouldn't even really think
superheroes and super villains were a
big deal just like normal yeah
superheroes that's what yeah that's why
i'm glad you said about unbreakable
because that's kind of like everybody's
just like yeah superheroes they exist
and like i said they're not it's not
like they're
you know it's not like i'm gonna snap my
fingers and like wipe out half the
population or anything like that like in
the marvel movies the guy is just
impervious to bullets it seems like or
he can heal up like he does get hurt
yeah now didn't they say like his main
weakness was that you know if he gets
real [ __ ] up
um he gets like he gets over like his
body overheats as he's healing up so
that was kind of like funny that like he
opened the fridge and there was all that
like ice cream in there and he said he
just eats all his eye cream oh and what
was the deal with him like eating the
cereal and pouring apple juice on it
that was a good idea
lower fat
lower fat you know you know you know sly
put that in there because no you don't
put milk in there and they're like where
you put the almond milk no no no you put
out but we put apple juice
it's like something sly would do apple
juice probably good and cheerios
cheerios or maybe apple jacks i think it
was cheerios would it oh i don't know
what it was in the movie i was just just
hypothetically curious and i was like
yeah it's probably good
and it's probably those frosted cheerios
and the ones that are glazed the honey
nut cheerios yeah probably what they
were
with apple juice that'd be real good
yeah probably yeah i mean i don't get
into a damn food processor and blend it
into like a shake with some ice and
drink it you have heavy fiber in there
yeah yeah
put your protein in there that sounds
really gross yeah but um
you're all [ __ ] jacked on royce
you're well done give me that give me
that
well yeah you have to be the lady you
want to drink that crap but yes that's
what i mean i was i was actually reading
an article the other day because i told
him about this about some i can't
remember what company it was but they
made a cereal that was supposed to be
uh made for
eating with orange juice instead of milk
but they did like a taste test on it and
they said it was revolting so i don't so
i don't really know but i mean apple
juice like i said it would depend on the
cereal yeah like maybe if it was
cheerios or i would say it might be okay
i don't know or it might be strange i'm
not really sure be like just some kind
of like the the textural component might
be kind of odd i don't know
you're making me want to go try it
i try that do we have any apple juice no
no i thought we have some orange juice
maybe yeah it wouldn't be the same but
yeah orange juice is it's yeah in the
movie it was apple juice and i just like
thought that was funny and i like that
they didn't explain it like they
explained to the ice cream thing like
why he had all that ice cream and that's
all that was in his freezer he was
watching his health but
milk's not really that good for you
it's high in calorie it's got a bunch of
lactic acid in it
it's not that good for you adults aren't
really supposed to be drinking milk
i mean you can have it just you don't
want to drink a lot of it
you know
danny rowling said yeah there were zero
cops throughout the movie when in
reality there would be helicopters in
the whole shebang well i kind of feel
like that's what i mean it just seemed
like it was not
more of a throwback to like 80s and 90s
for words like this neighborhood is so
blighted yeah that the cops won't even
go there so i kind of i kind of thought
that they that was the vibe that they
were going for that this city had
they're just like [ __ ] it we wash our
hands of it like they had cops obviously
because the guys like broke into the
thing to get the hammer but
they're i just kind of feel like it was
just kind of a thing where crime was
happening and they're just like nah
whatever yeah like just let it happen i
lived in detroit for about 16 months
almost two years
no you could shoot somebody in detroit
and just walk off
yeah yeah there weren't many cops it
happened all the time i found a [ __ ]
dead guy in my [ __ ]
behind the building within the [ __ ]
dumpster his [ __ ] feet sticking up by
the dumpster frozen
frozen feet his shoes gone
yeah well he didn't wasn't gonna need
the [ __ ] i had to go to work
you know yeah let somebody else in
building [ __ ] call this is like oh
[ __ ]
they were killing each other all the
time it was a murder capital of the
world and it was [ __ ] now it's all
mostly torn down where the
neighborhood's around it and it's just
it's returned to nature they [ __ ]
tore down whole blocks you know you
could see it on youtube no there there
are cities that collapsed here in the
united states that are just
one-sixth the size of what they used to
be
you know just just 20 years ago
just shrank down to nothing
so uh and a lot of it's because there
was no real law and order but there
weren't that many people either it was
weird it just collapsed
it's how it's how it happened in ancient
times too
that's how you end up finding the city
it's nothing but just [ __ ] stone
blocks
danny rowling said i didn't see the plot
twist coming until it came um i saw it
yeah and i and i kind of feel like even
like i said i was reading like a review
of it and some of the comments on there
said i haven't even seen the movie but
just from your description of the movie
i know what the plot twist is gonna be
yeah but um like i said i don't really
wanna spoil it at least in the you know
at least on the audio or anything like
that but i didn't realize this was
directed
by the same guy uh julius avery's
australian guy the same guy that
directed overlord do you remember that
uh like the nazis with the thing yeah i
didn't like it yeah that's what i
thought like you know like that was like
his last main movie it was 2018. and
actually he was supposed to
they were gonna do that remake of flash
gordon and he was supposed to like do
that but then like it got shuffled
around and i don't think they're gonna
do it now and i think it got cancelled
they should never ever [ __ ] do flash
gordon they they can't well it's not
going to be the same they can't handle
flashboard it's not going to be the same
yeah they would try to like make it all
like
acceptable by today's story well no they
would try to make it all like you know
dark and gritty and stuff like that and
it's just like that's not what's fun
about like flash gordon and flash gordon
was about sex and drugs in space
and and booty and and crazy [ __ ] and the
ale and the aliens were basically
dressed up like they came out damn
chinese restaurant it was just
that's what flash quarter was all right
and it was colorful like you just
dropped some acid
it's
it'll they could never do that today
and it was
if you watch the old [ __ ]
flash gordon cereals you know it was
kind of before a lot of those weird
codes and you don't know if that you're
like this is made for kids they're
drinking love potions and half nude
women [ __ ] dripping off [ __ ] big
forearm satanic satanic [ __ ] statues
of the mango god and [ __ ] you know just
you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's his name
princess zara you know [ __ ] ming's
daughter is trying to [ __ ]
capture
flash to be her sex slave you know that
that's you know it's but you know
dino did the rent just got it right it
was that that's what it was
they just kind of compressed it down
into a too small of an episode that
needed to be three or four movies
rob says jenny i watched super dark
times good film not sure about the
ending though yeah i could see that i
wasn't i don't know i wasn't a massive
fan of the ending like i said i don't
really want to uh spoil it but overall i
really really liked that movie a lot
um
so oh here's another thing too the guy
that plays cyrus in this the and cause
you kept saying where the [ __ ] have i
seen that guy before like he's so
familiar that guy is actually danish
okay and uh his big thing i think
everybody mostly knows him from game of
thrones but i don't think you've uh seen
that but he was also an overlord and he
was in uh lucy with scarlett johansson
and he was in ghost in the shell
so maybe you saw him maybe you
remembered him from overlord or ghost in
the shower yeah because i know you've
never seen game of thrones and i think
that's where everybody knows ghost in
the shell was
okay
there were some problems with it from
what i remember but i liked the way it
looked
just remember there wasn't a whole lot
it wasn't really a whole lot of a story
to ghost yeah it didn't really i
remember it not being terrible but it
didn't really make much of an impression
yeah on me either i just remember it
visually it looked pretty good but there
just wasn't much there in terms of story
i kind of feel like that happens a lot
with those types of like big like yeah
maybe it's just because one i'm not a
real big sci-fi person like i like some
sci-fi movies but it's not usually my
go-to genre and so i don't know like if
i haven't seen like because that was
kind of based on you know the the anime
or whatever and i was just like so i'm
not really into that either so i don't
really have kind of like the background
where i'm gonna be like ooh like all
into it and so a lot of it will just
either kind of go over my head or i'll
just be like
battle agent was far better
well yeah i mean that
was really good and they never came back
with a [ __ ] sequel you know [ __ ] them
[ __ ] those dudes danny rowling said yeah
i got the same feeling about the cyrus
actor which i felt like i've seen him
before but clearly haven't and i didn't
maybe it was because like i said he
looked very much like
uh kiefer sutherland circa the lost boys
like he had the same kind of hair that's
what i'm saying they were really kind of
going for that because his whole like
gang
like of
people like his lackeys and stuff like
that looked very much like over the top
like uh like a gang would have looked in
the 80s or 90s kind of movie you know
what i mean it was just very kind of
like over the top but i see i feel like
it wasn't over the top
enough for it to be
like a thing like we're doing like an
homage or something like that you know
what i'm saying i don't know it was like
a weird
like it seemed like it wasn't
it was it seemed like it was trying to
be retro but not enough that it was like
really obvious yeah david june got it
right flash gordon was there in silver
underwear that's right
and that's from that song from rocky
horror is it yeah okay yeah all right
but i thought he was wearing he was
wearing underwear when he got it when
she got him out of that damn
casket and dressed him up and tried to
sneak him away remember that yeah rhys
flying yeah he's flying the ship and
she's trying to get it on with him when
he's do you talking to dale
telepathically and [ __ ]
with the telepathic cell phone
yeah yeah but yeah that's what he was
that was uh that song from rocky horror
pictures like the
that's how it goes yeah that was like
the first line of that song
and his underwear wasn't silver
in the movie
remember she made him undress
yeah but in the they were talking i
thought in the rocky horror song i
thought they were talking about the
cereal like the old one so which was in
black and white so i'm going to say no
yeah um danny rowling said i think the
cyrus actor is going to be in a salem's
lot remake
yeah
yeah maybe
i just kind of [ __ ] yeah i thought i'd
seen him seen him before too now i had
seen
we did see overlord and i did see ghost
in the shell so maybe we did but i i
kind of feel like i thought i'd seen him
before because he looked like [ __ ]
keepers overlord was stupid i didn't
like overlord i didn't mind it my unit
was involved in the real operation
overlord that was a real
that was a real uh [ __ ] airborne
operation and they just [ __ ]
butchered the historicity of [ __ ]
the 101st airborne division and
you know
it was a segregated service at that time
they're showing it as integrated and i'm
like come on why are we why why are we
[ __ ] uh denying the way [ __ ] really
was back then yeah but it was a fantasy
movie it was like you know what i mean
it's just kind of like it's fiction so
you can kind of do whatever you want
with it it's like also it's alternative
history right that's there's a whole sub
genre
of alternate history type of stuff that
was like that yeah overlord was just a
real operation in this universe though
you know and [ __ ] that was just like
a it's like somebody retail yeah no it
doesn't matter
yeah but you know it's like be like
somebody retelling the [ __ ]
so-called massacre wounded knee or
something and then making it so the
indians were the bad guys you know if i
could no
i'm sure somebody's done that somewhere
yeah no u.s army [ __ ] slaughtered a
bunch of indians over a misunderstanding
about the damn ghost dance
and and they accidentally shot a deaf
dude because he wouldn't put the gun
down he couldn't hear him and that
started the [ __ ] massacre well see
that's yeah i mean and then they tried
to [ __ ] spin that as well they were
rising up to kill [ __ ] uh people in
their neighboring towns the the indians
doing the ghost dances was christians
they were christian indians just [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] you know you aren't the
history's filled with all kinds of
convoluted [ __ ]
narratives of what happens on [ __ ]
like that
danny rowling also says that cyrus guy
looks like michael shannon kind of oh
yeah he kind of does he kind of does if
kiefer sutherland and michael shannon uh
somehow had a baby yeah he kind of does
look like that
i might have seen him in some other
stuff because i know he's danish and
he's been like in a lot of danish
language stuff so maybe i've seen him in
one of those things because i would be
more willing to watch that kind of stuff
than than you would but yeah it's this
is it's fine it's a fine pg-13
action movie we always like sylvester
stallone yeah it's cool that he's like
in his 70s and he's still like out there
and he still looks good and he's still
playing like a superhero i'm sure like
some of the [ __ ] they had to do like
stunt doubles or whatever but
um but you know he's still out there
having a good time yeah i i feel like oh
i follow him on instagram he posts stuff
all the time
they just uh he just finished making a
movie it looked like some kind of a neo
western it was there it looks like they
were in i don't remember what it was
called but um the cast was there
and he's up all in his damn texas suit
with his little [ __ ] cowboy boots and
[ __ ] people applauding him and all his
friends he's in good shape man
for 70 something
still still some gas in the tank yeah
what is he 75 76 yeah he actually looks
i think he looks better
now in the face at least uh than he
looked in that rambo um in that
not the last rambo movie the one before
the fight continues where yeah the good
one the one that was really good
the super gory one yeah yeah like
his face look kind of [ __ ] up that at
that one i think yeah it looked like
like i said it looked like somebody put
their foot on the back of his head and
pulled
the staple i think uh human growth
hormone he was taking that kind of it
has a tendency to distort your [ __ ]
face and give you big lips and [ __ ] like
that but it looks like he fixed it
um
because your [ __ ] facial features
start [ __ ] growing under it
um
you know and everybody knows you know
he's not he's not natural he's [ __ ]
ben jack but i'm i'm surprised he's been
taking androgens
since his [ __ ] 20s in the late 20s
probably mid to late 20s i think [ __ ]
rambo three he was
working with [ __ ] what was his name
oh [ __ ]
i can't remember the thing
zayn the friend i think frank zane was a
guy's name i don't remember who's
training him
and so he was he was taking stuff back
then
it's hard to believe he's still able to
[ __ ]
take stuff there's usually not enough
gas left in the tank by the time they
hit their 50s their [ __ ] heart valves
are [ __ ] tore up what are you doing
pokey they kind of have a grainy look to
their skin
so what happened to arnold man he [ __ ]
his heart up
he grew up taking nfr pills by [ __ ]
17 18 years old
so by the time he was 50 something his
heart valves were [ __ ] shot because
you're just not supposed to be that big
even though he got lighter if you look
at him in predator one he's not that big
he looks good though
but
i don't know i [ __ ] when you see him
when he was sucking
you know in his 20s he was [ __ ] huge
he was a huge
so that probably puts a lot of stress on
your heart it catches up with you
uh
catches up with you eventually
but you know so i'm just what i'm saying
was stallone is that he's he's held out
a long time
yeah and i mean yeah and he's always
kind of doing some interesting projects
i think we've talked about this before
because i've always been more of a fan
of sylvester stallone just because you
know yeah he was in like a lot of action
movies and stuff like that but he was
also like a writer
and that's kind of how he started out
like i mean he was [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] iconic
[ __ ] that he did like rocky and
everything like that so so he actually
had
he wasn't just you know muscle he had
like other [ __ ] like
substance to him for some of you younger
audience members
if there was there was a rivalry between
arnold schwarzenegger and and sylvester
stallone goes way back they were trying
to who was the best dude in hollywood
and
look man they both had some [ __ ]
great movies they were both good but
they had different strengths and
weaknesses
arnold's strength is that he had good
charisma all right
he he could pull a movie off if the
script was good some of them were
[ __ ] really good some of them
were just mediocre
but arnold was always a fantasy
character in a way he was never really
realistic
i would think playing dutch out of
predator one is the closest he ever got
to realism in those old movies
sylvester stallone was a real actor
okay and he could write he was very
talented
um he was a good balance of stuff he had
good physicality this isn't his first
superhero movie you could say you know
this first one probably judge dredd
yeah like a superhero movie and i liked
i liked the old judge dredd it didn't it
wasn't close to the comic books but it's
just it's just good good good movie to
watch you know and demolition man
[ __ ] still holds up there's a
demolition man's more relevant now than
it ever was
[ __ ]
a lot of that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
predictive of where society would want
to go you know um
just he had some real good [ __ ] and we
talked about how good the remake of
judge dredd was that was actually one of
one of the better uh yeah remakes
remake judge dredds very good yeah it's
excellent yeah
still not close to the to the comic book
the comic book was almost just damn
bizarre as [ __ ] it was surreal
for judge dredd
it wasn't realistic it was kind of like
a satire in a certain way
satire for fascism
but uh that gives me a way to call it
just
overbearing governments you know
but uh no it's a decent stallone movie
it did its job
you know it's good
yeah
hugo said first blood is great of course
yeah of course i mean he did a bunch of
really good ones all the rabbit movies
were good yeah at least they were some
of them were better than others but the
the worst ones were still good
yeah they're all watchable they're all
watchable yeah and like i said you still
need to see some of uh
sylvester stallone's kind of more
serious roles
like cop land or something like that
like i said i saw that in the theater
you probably like really like that but
it's just so he can like he can act i
mean the thing about it is that arnold
schwarzenegger can act too
now like now that they give him like
like i said we've talked about that
zombie movie mag yeah he was actually
really good at that but he's gotten a
lot better like arnie played himself a
lot yeah he had his own role that he did
you know with the silly one-liners and
[ __ ] and that was the 80s
um
he could
you couldn't put him in a movie that was
really about acting and you know like in
the old school theatrical way what the
hell would you hire arnie to do that for
head guys that did that arnie was
somebody that showed up [ __ ] blew a
movie out of the water you know over the
top stuff
to this day you know out of all the
[ __ ] masterpieces people would say
you know t2 or predator one
t1
terminator 1. that's
that's arnie's best work
he does it only says a few things in it
but
arne is such a he's a [ __ ] badass
villain he's a better hero he's a better
villain than he is a hero
but i know why he didn't want that in
his contract because he'd been typecast
but
he's just a [ __ ]
killer robot and
man although [ __ ] conan won
i stand by a lot of his old stuff
yeah
when yeah when he's playing a character
that's inhuman or larger than life yeah
then yeah that's kind of his goal too
that's his go-to yeah if you need
somebody that's just like a regular dude
then sylvester stallone is good right
right or somebody who's a little more
realistic like you'd be like yeah a guy
like that could exist the closest thing
in in in
in in [ __ ]
arnold's classic catalog the closest
thing to him playing a real guy is
playing dutch from predator one
and i believe carl weathers told a story
about that he said that he got that
acting out of him and i believe that
because i can call would just drive [ __ ]
would just drive arnold by how he
couldn't act
he just pushed him and pushed him and
[ __ ] trolled him and trolled him
until he acted real until he acted
realistic in those scenes i don't doubt
that that's carl's story
but i noticed that [ __ ]
out of the classic movies
carl weathers happens to be in that same
movie carl said i got him acting good
[Laughter]
probably true yeah probably probably
true probably because carl can act yeah
carl's also [ __ ] talented he's he
wrote at least one of those mandalorian
episodes it was a good episode
yeah that's right i saw it yeah he's
good too
all right i can't believe they didn't
make a damn second action jackson i saw
that in the theater i [ __ ] loved it
no no we should probably do a movie
retrospective on that one of these days
because i haven't seen that since i was
i haven't seen it since i saw the
theater yeah i don't think i've seen it
since then either yeah
i was like oh man this is badass i
remember liking it but i don't think i
ever saw it again yeah i was waiting for
the [ __ ] you know i said there'll be
a sequel to that one and that was during
the time when arnold was [ __ ] huge
too and the sequel never appeared forgot
all about it
maybe they like it's just one of those
things it's like you know maybe maybe
they had it going and then it's like
various things happen yeah the market
must have changed by the time because
the studios are like well that wouldn't
sell now we got to do we got to go in
this direction i think die hard came out
and that changed everything
oh yeah that was the end right that was
the end of that kind of action hero
which is a [ __ ] big muscular dude
those guys went out of style
so i think i think die hard probably
killed some stuff yeah because that was
more of like an every man type
situation it was that era had ended so
carl went out with that and he had to
[ __ ] find a new way to make money
yeah i guess so yeah you're probably
right about that because i was watching
a whole it might have been on
was it that netflix show movies that
made us i think they did a whole episode
on die hard and they talked a lot about
that like what a big cultural
impact that die hard had when it came
off because it was like such a huge
success yeah and you know at that time
it's you know it's hard to
remember like nowadays but if you
weren't around back then but bruce
willis was i mean he was a tv actor and
he was a comedian like he was a funny
guy yeah nobody believed that movie
would do it and nobody really thought
that he could be like an action hero per
se but then he came out like you said he
was just like an everyman type of dude
but then like you know he just used
perseverance and various other things
and cunning and whatnot and uh so it was
like a huge success so i think after
that like action movies went more in
that direction and he did all that [ __ ]
barefoot with his feet cut up yeah
wrapped in rags and [ __ ] and the
fight scenes were very realistic for the
day and uh when i saw die hard that
changed the game too like oh yeah yeah
this is this is the way it needs to go
this is a good movie
the sequels weren't bad either but they
progressively got more stale you know
well i mean that's pretty much what
always remember part two was okay
that's that's all i remember remember
the other ones i was like
[Music]
all right so you getting ready to wrap
it up because like i said i gotta start
uh getting ready because we're going out
we're having a special memento mori this
evening at barbarella danny rowling said
what's tomorrow's a haunting episode
yeah i'll be very happy excited happy
and excited to know that it's finally
we're finally doing legend trippers
uh we just watched it last night and i
actually watched it again today and like
took a bunch of notes and
uh you know got some outside info about
it and [ __ ] like that so that's the one
we're gonna be doing tomorrow hopefully
we're not horribly too hungover but i'd
see we have all day to like recover it's
not until 6 pm but uh but yeah so like i
said this movie samaritan if you like
superhero movies and want to see
something a little bit different if you
like sylvester stallone it's on amazon
prime you can watch it it's pretty it's
pretty good it's it was it was good it
was a good time uh but yeah so we'll see
you guys again tomorrow for a haunting
mondays again legend trippers so we'll
see you then
bye